in 1861 two scientists got into a very
brainy argument specifically they had
opposing ideas of how speech and memory
operated within the human brain
Ernest Ober tall with his local istic
model argued that a particular region of
the brain was devoted to each separate
process
Pierre Grazia lay on the other hand
argued for the distributed model where
different regions work together to
accomplish all of these various
functions the debate they began
reverberating throughout the rest of the
century involving some of the greatest
scientific minds of the time
Hobart all and his local istic model had
some big names on his side in the 17th
century Rene Descartes had assigned the
quality of free will and the human soul
to the pineal gland and in the late 18th
century a young student named Franz
Joseph gall had observed that the best
memorizers in his class had the most
prominent eyes and decided that this was
due to higher development in the
adjacent part of the brain as a
physician gall went on to establish the
study of phrenology which held that
strong mental faculties correspond to
highly developed brain regions
observable as bumps in the skull the
widespread popularity of phrenology
throughout the early 19th century tipped
the scales toward overtones localism but
the problem was that gall had never
bothered to scientifically test whether
the individual brain maps he had
constructed applied to all people and in
the 1840s Pierre Flourens challenged
phrenology by selectively destroying
parts of animal brains and observing
which functions were lost
Florence found that damaging the cortex
interfered with judgment or movement in
general but failed to identify any
region associated with one specific
function concluding that the cortex
carried out brain functions as an entire
unit Florence had scored a victory for
grotty au lait but it was not to last
Gauls former student jean-baptiste buyo
challenged Firenze conclusion observing
that patients with speech disorders all
had damage to the frontal lobe and after
Paul Broca's 1861 autopsy of a patient
who had lost the power to
do speech but not the power to
understand it revealed highly localized
frontal lobe damage the distributed
model seemed doomed localism took off in
the 1870s Carl Veronica associated part
of the left temporal lobe with speech
comprehension soon after Edward Heath
Sieg and Gustav rich stimulated a dog's
cortex and discovered a frontal lobe
region responsible for muscular
movements building on their work David
Fourier mapped each piece of cortex
associated with moving a part of the
body and in 1909 Corbin Ian Broadman
built his own cortex map with 52
separate areas it appeared that the
victory of Ober tollans local istic
model was sealed
but neurologist carl veronica had come
up with an interesting idea he reasoned
that since the regions for speech
production and comprehension were not
adjacent then injuring the area
connecting them might result in a
special type of language loss now known
as receptive aphasia
Veronica's connectionist model helped
explain disorders that didn't result
from the dysfunction of just one area
modern neuroscience tools reveal a brain
more complex than gratia lay over tall
or even Veronica imagined today the
hippocampus is associated with two
distinct brain functions creating
memories and processing location in
space we also now measure two kinds of
connectivity anatomical connectivity
between two adjoining regions of cortex
working together and functional
connectivity between separated regions
working together to accomplish one
process a seemingly basic function like
vision is actually composed of many
smaller functions with different parts
of the cortex representing shape color
and location in space when certain areas
stop functioning we may recognize an
object but not see it or vice versa
there are even different kinds of memory
for facts and for routines and
remembering something like your first
bicycle involves a network of different
regions each representing the concept of
vehicles the bicycles shape the sound of
the Bell and the emotions associated
with that memory in the end both grotty
Ola and uber tall turned out to be right
and we still use both of their models
to understand how cognition happens for
example we can now measure brain
activity on such a fine timescale that
we can see the individual localized
processes that comprise a single act of
remembering but it is the integration of
these different processes and regions
that creates the coherent memory we
experience the supposedly competing
theories proved to be two aspects of a
more comprehensive model which will in
turn be revised and refined as our
scientific technologies and methods for
understanding the brain improve